chaque président a reçu personnel et que
j'ai du film qui est plus ou moins gde
plus que social que j'y serai
effectivement de donner une petite
touche personnelle à cette à cette
mandature qui ne doit durer que konami
puisque je suis président jusqu'à la fin
du mois de leur engagement pour moi
c'est quelque chose de fondamental le
respect même de de cet engagement de la
parole donnée la présence aux unions la
présence aux missions vous ont été
confiées
tout ça pour moi c'est fondamental et
nous avons été élus sur un programme
il est grand temps que je vous dise que
nous avons changé de formule parce que
nous étions devenus collectivités
territoriales déjà ça c'est qu'il faut
savoir et
il fallait donc refaire des statuts et
règlement intérieur ce qui avait été
fait donc avant l'assemblée générale
d'avril 2010 8 et on est devenus au
conseil exécutif
neuf personnes deux secrétaires de
trésorier président et quatre vice
présidents qui ont chacun une mission
bien précise avec des changes donné par
le cnf et puis six personnes puisque
nous sommes à vos 7 à l'initiation de
caisse qui viennent de ligue et des
clubs des comités affiliés et et et ce
travail
son programme était déjà défini
concernant donc la caraïbe des actions
sociales des actions de politique
publique etc tout ça et c'est largement
engagée l'association c'est un endroit
où en dehors même de la famille baud
sont enrichis on sollicite beaucoup
c'est vrai que c'est un complément je le
dis tous les jours quand on est bénévole
et qu'on conchos 3 ide pouvoir se mettre
à disposition de deux autres mois pour
moi c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
je vais encourager
mais quand on vient travailler ensemble
au-delà du conseil d'administration même
si de temps en temps on est on est pas
d'accord avec ce que dit loeb qui est en
face de nous il faut savoir écouter
entame et préfère de tolérabilité
parce que c'est toujours un
enrichissement mois jusqu'à présent
après le petit nombre d'années 53 cents
au dessus président va vous dire que
jusqu'à briser se retirer en pointe de
tous les comités des associations où je
suis nous assumons et je crois que c'est
ça justement cette richesse que nous
donne la vie associative et c'est pour
ça que le passionné que je suis souhaite
avoir la santé vous continuer le plus
longtemps possible